One of the main reasons someone would use DMS. Oh, so DMSO is diamethyl sulfonxide.
It
Is a became very popular back in the 1970s, 80s
as a strong anti-inflammatory agent for joint
inflammation and people with bad knees, bad shoulders, and things. It's a liquid like a water.
People have taken it early for inflammation.
And then it kind of fell out of sort. I've got bad notes by that.
You know medical association, the medical establishment, and
slowly kind of fell out of sort, but it is a very strong anti-inflammatory
product. You could buy it on Amazon now again.
You could, it's a, it is a driving agent. So you have to do it to be careful with
using it topically. And if you had, let's say,
a lotion on your skin or dirty skin or
you know, a solvent like gasoline or something like that on your skin.
And you put DMSO over it with literally really drive that into your bloodstream.
So you want to have clean skin if you're going to use it topically or you're using it topically as a driving agent
to, let's say, drive an essential oil or something into your body.
But you have to be careful with that because an essential oil can be
toxic at high doses. So you do have to be careful using it in that sense.
I know there are some cancer protocols that use DMSO orally, but they're using fairly
low doses. I would be, you know, cautious about doing that.
We have used DMSO topically with zinc to drive zinc into the tissues.
Zinc deficiency can be common with certain cancers.
Copper toxicity is common across the board, which is with cancer.
But copper and zinc kind of compete with each other.
There's a balance between copper and zinc in the tissues.
And when people have a zinc deficiency, you can build up too much copper.
And copper can be a driver of cancer because it could be a driver of growth.
And then you could end up with a copper toxicity issues,
especially when people have gotten into Instagram fans of using copper,
you know, in their cooking and thinking that, you know,
more copper is better for you, which, you know, copper is an element of the periodic table.
It can function like a heavy metal. It's typically considered more of a mineral,
but it's needed in certain metabolic processes of the body, but it's needed in very low doses.
So when you're taking elemental copper,
as some of these Instagrammers are pushing, you can easily end up with
copper toxicity. And if you remember your genetics, there are copper transport genes,
and there's copper detoxifying genes. And some people are going to defects in that,
and they're going to be more prone to copper toxicity issues that don't get rid of copper very well.
So we can end up acting like a heavy metal toxicity in their body.
Zinc can tend to push that out. So zinc, you know, that copper zinc ratio is good to measure
with cancer patients, because Betty cancers, for instance, one known cancer is prostate cancer,
could have excess copper issues and have zinc deficiencies. So taking zinc orally is one way
to help combat that. But sometimes, you know, the absorb your nutrients very well for all sorts
of other reasons, inflammation of the gut, et cetera. So using a DMSO with a zinc to drive zinc
into the tissues, especially if you want to drive it into a specific area, can be beneficial.
So those would be the main reasons why someone would use DMSO.